what's going on guys this is rob and
just in time for the shang chi movie
marvel has been releasing a comic
actually shang chi's on solo series
called shang chi versus the marvel
universe where quite literally he kind
of takes it in turn to face off against
different people right so in this video
we're covering his fight with spider-man
after that you go into captain america
then you go into wolverine then you go
onto the fantastic four and then i don't
know who the final one is or maybe
there's only a couple left i'm not 100
sure but regardless this fight here
takes place between shang qi and
spider-man which is kind of cool because
there's a little bit of history here now
initially this picks up with sheng chi
on a dinner date with a girl by the name
of delilah wang who of course he's been
trying to get with for quite some time
the problem is that in the middle of
this date he keeps getting hit up by his
younger sister esme because she's
basically on what is in effect a
stakeout right tracing or attracting
this guy for the purpose of trying to
find what is basically a giant drug ring
going on in the city of new york now one
thing that i want to specify here when
it comes to shane chi and this is kind
of a a little might be a little bit of a
misconception here shang chi was never
really more than a street level
superhero he was never really like a big
avengers roster kind of guy the only
time he ever really saw that happen was
during hickman's avengers and new
avengers and really only because the
situation was so dire right literally
the collapse of the multiverse and also
because by way of some craziness going
on with earth and it gaining sentience
he basically gained the ability to
duplicate himself but under any normal
circumstance the really the biggest
change he's ever been as far as being
part of like a great big huge superhero
team has really been the significant
role he played in heroes for hire that
said he has kind of been on the avengers
off and on over the years but again
never really any major notable moments
for his character the big thing about
this though is that you actually end up
having an instance where esme just kind
of ignores the entire orders given to
her by her brother and literally grabs
this guy and brings him to the
restaurant like literally throws him
against the window right now one of the
things that ends up happening here is
shane cheese being referred to as what's
called brother hand and the reason why
is because he's now the supreme
commander of the five weapons society
now this is a big deal the five weapons
society is actually gone by a bunch of
different names over the years but the
five weapon society was the organization
founded by zing zhu who's the father of
shang chi of course he wasn't originally
the father of shang chi originally shang
chi's dad was fu manchu but through a
combination of marvel losing the rights
and the fact that the character was just
rooted in racism eventually that went
away and it just ended up becoming zheng
zhu instead but the important thing is
his villainous father was the one who
ran this entire operation the fact is
that zhing zhu's been dead for quite
some time and while the death of zing
zhu really just kind of allowed shang
chi to move away from the the ongoing
conflicts with his father and kind of
graduate out into the greater superhero
community what this is doing is actually
bringing him back into the fold to where
he's now the one that runs his dad's
operation but instead of being the
villain that we're familiar with right
shang chi just kind of being what his
dad you know essentially was instead he
maintains his superhero roots and
basically starts using the five weapons
society to start taking down all these
criminal elements starting with new york
city itself and so of course a big fight
breaks out between this guy and shang
chi and his sister esme and ultimately
this guy's defeated quite readily right
shanxi takes this guy out quick fast and
in a hurry only for his sister esme to
find a spider tracker on this guy's foot
and then spiderman arrives now the funny
thing about this is peter parker has
been basically tracking down or locating
a uh a weapons ring in the city of new
york itself now if we're being honest
with ourselves this is small time stuff
even for spider-man right spider-man
usually focuses on bigger things but it
is something that kind of draws his
attention and brings him here and one of
the reasons why if i'm being honest this
isn't really a big thing for spider-man
is because it happens all the time
usually it's wilson fisk who's behind it
right the kingpin who's behind like drug
rings weapon rings different things like
that but at the very least it draws the
attention of spider-man because i guess
it's a slow day and then in turn a kind
of fight little skirmish breaks out
between him and esme not super lengthy
mostly because esme knows who he is but
ultimately he got webbing on her daggers
right so she kind of gets pissed off
and kind of goes after peter of course
not a whole lot happening there but then
peter and shang chi pay their respects
to each other and the reason why is
because there's a lengthy history
between these guys specifically during
jonathan hickman's avengers new avengers
the reason why is because up to that
point in time spider-man usually fought
just using a combination of his
acrobatic abilities and his spider sense
and some common sense with shang chi he
actually learned a martial art style
called the way of the spider which was
basically blending kung fu with
spider-man's natural acrobatic abilities
it was cool right it was really really
awesome the funny thing here though is
that because of the fact that shanxi is
in effect spider-man's former sensei
right his martial arts master there's a
lot of respect to be had there and so
the results of this is that spider-man
actually approaches him and says hey
like i'm hunting a weapons ring you're
hunting a drug ring this is new york
there's no reason to believe they're not
working together let's team up and
initially change he's against it right
he's kind of like i mean you know
there's no real reason to believe our
two things are connected but ultimately
out of respect shang chi ends up siding
with spider-man and the two of them
start working together and so following
that one of the things that you see kind
of hit on here is that shang chi doesn't
really fall in line with the traditional
philosophies of the five weapons society
insofar as how they function their
hierarchy different things like that and
so where his sister largely reveres him
as the leader of the organization shanxi
plays that role but doesn't really want
to have a whole lot to do with it right
and so that's why his sister really
seems to chastise him quite a bit like
you're the leader of the five weapon
society it's time for you to start
acting like a leader right start acting
with the kind of pride that a person in
this role would have as opposed to shang
chi just kind of being like all right
look i'm here but i'm only really
interested in taking down and basically
dismantling my father's organization and
then using it for a system of good right
but ultimately they end up finding
themselves coming across a traditional
chinese medicine shop and once you get
in there you actually end up having this
kind of discussion between esme and this
shop owner while spider-man and shang
chi go off to try to find what's going
on with this whole great big huge ring
and so on and so forth and so ultimately
sb approaches this guy and basically
says look like we know that what's going
on here is you're running a drug ring
right you're not fooling anybody we know
that's what's happening here and
ultimately this guy kind of tells her a
story about how at one point in time he
was a servant to a very powerful man and
that his life essentially changed when
he came across a urine which i'm not 100
sure this is accurate or not but as it's
depicted here is basically a chinese
yeti and he brings this to his master
who was actually zheng zhu and he
developed what was called the urine root
which is basically this this item right
this sort of uh piece of this particular
urine that would actually allow a person
to bestow themselves with the power of a
yeti and what this guy had been doing in
working for zhing zhu over the years is
he had actually found a way to
essentially synthesize it and give it to
the forces of zhang zhu now this is
designed to kind of bookend into why it
is that in the early days of the shang
chi stories when zheng zhu had henchmen
that almost looked like an animal man to
a degree why that happened this is
basically that explanation here and
ultimately what you end up learning is
this guy built an entire organization
around it right that those individuals
and seemingly not even just zhengzu's
forces but basically anybody out there
who could likely pay the money to do it
would come to the sky and then acquire
these abilities and then go engage in
whatever action they wanted to engage in
but this guy was given the name king
wild man by zing zhu and it served him
loyally along with the rest of the five
weapon society without any reservation
just because of what zheng zhu had done
for him now at that point you switch
over to spider-man and uh and shang chi
who of course have tracked down and
located this kind of weapons ring really
an extension with this drug ring but
spider-man of course ends up tripping a
infrared sensor now one of the funny
things here is that in the early days
when shang chi was training spider-man
in the way of the spider one of the
things he said is that your spider sense
or his fighter sense was fairly limited
and that if he were to meditate like
he's supposed to his spider sense could
reach a whole new level of power to the
point that it's not really just you know
realizing that some threat is facing him
but would actually warn him if he's
going to trip like motion sensors and
different things like that right so just
kind of giving him this sort of overall
awareness of every facet of his
environment including what you would
consider to be inanimate objects and so
kind of a fight breaks out between all
these guys spider-man shanghai you know
spider-man ends up coming out on top and
then of course the fight ends up
involving this old tea shop owner along
with esme and everything kind of pops
off now spider-man helps this guy get to
his feet and that's when he ends up
grabbing the urine root and then bonding
it to spider-man and so following that
as working as kind of a henchman for the
five or at least uh for what would be
zhang zhu really on behalf of this shop
owner spider-man ends up attacking shang
chi now this is kind of a cool little
fight it's not lengthy it's not a super
long fight honestly because it doesn't
need to be but it is a bit of a cool
fight here and the reason why is because
it's designed to showcase the power of
shang chi when it comes to shang chi
himself he doesn't really have any
traditional abilities right he's not
like the iron fist danny rand where he
can focus all of his qi energy into like
a glowing fist and punch through
seemingly anything right it's not really
like that instead it's just an
incredible knowledge of martial arts but
one of the things that makes sheng chi
so capable is that in the greater
pantheon of fighters in marvel comics
the only person i would really say is
more capable than this guy would be
taskmaster and only because of the fact
that taskmaster can basically watch
shang chi fight which he's done and then
basically copy his fighting style to the
point that he can actually predict what
change he's going to do before he does
it it's what makes taskmaster so capable
but captain america spider-man all those
guys they would all fall before the
power of shang chi that's just how
capable he is and so when this fight
happens despite the fact that spider-man
has been amped up in terms of its
capabilities he's stronger he's faster
right he's just far more dangerous
shang's still able to basically out
maneuver him now a lot of this is really
just because of the fact that spider-man
probably seems to be fighting mindless
here right there doesn't really seem to
be a whole lot of peter parker's mind in
here because he's being controlled now
again a lot of this i think is based off
his experience fighting both against and
alongside peter parker in terms of him
having been a member of the superhero
community and having been the the
instructor of peter teaching him the way
of the spider so he's really familiar
very intimately familiar with all the
different weaknesses that peter parker
has in terms of his fighting style when
you combine that with the fact that
peter's fighting mindlessly well this
fight was over before it even started
and so what you actually end up having
is them basically using the webbing of
peter as he's shooting it to essentially
ensnare him up right and that's one of
the big things about shang qi is that
despite him being a martial arts master
when you have him facing off against
people with powers there's not a whole
lot you can do and that's why you
actually see him using his brain as much
as his body when it comes to these
conflicts using his environment to win
battles that he otherwise wouldn't
normally win so ensnaring spider-man in
his own webbing is the smartest move
here it's the smartest thing to do of
course with spider-man having a little
you know the thing removed from his face
shang chi really begins the process of
kind of living up to his role as the
supreme commander of the five weapons
society and really kind of starts
following the advice his sister's giving
him where he basically calls everybody
in and it's like okay look like this is
the role that i play if i'm going to be
the leader of the five weapon society i
gotta be the leader here right i gotta
play this role and so instead of giving
peter the opportunity to actually take
this whole weapon sting hand it over to
the cops and allow the cops to either
continue or launch their own
investigation instead he's like it's all
coming with me whether you wanted to or
not peter parker is irrelevant it's all
coming with me right these are all
weapons that belong to my organization
they're being used for nefarious acts
i'm taking them all back right this is
uncharacteristic of shang chi normally
he would work with peter and then
ultimately say okay let's hand this over
to the authorities they're the ones best
suited to handle this instead he's not
giving peter that opportunity and that's
why spider-man asks like this is this is
weird that you're you're doing this man
it's not like you to be like this are
you still one of us like are you still a
hero and the only real response he gets
is what does your spider sense tell you
and then he basically ends up leaving
right he basically ends up taking off
and so again it's kind of a wonky thing
because you do get a little bit of a
kind of backup feature here where this
little tea shop owner is kind of met by
a mysterious figure who's like yes i
know that shang chi dismantled your
entire operation overnight even though
it took you years to build it up but
i've got an offer for you king wild man
right so we don't know who that guy is
but let me know if you guys are
interested in seeing the rest of this
right chiang chi fighting captain
america shang chi fighting wolverine
which is a pretty cool fight ultimately
finding the fantastic four to whatever
end this happens to be but let me know
if you guys are interested in seeing
this right with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end let me
know if you guys enjoyed this and i will
catch you all later
peace
you